you have to be unique
if you're in a competitive market
there's lots of competition doing
exactly what you're doing you have to
find a way to be unique and stand out
and be different to capture people's
attention i got a great question from
one of my readers nick nick wants to
start a promotional products company
he's actually already started it but
it's part time and he wants to be able
to leave his full-time job
to make this business happen and he's
wondering how do i get more sales for
this company nick
the promotional product space is one of
the most competitive businesses out
there and if you are only competing on
price
you're going to lose people are racing
to the bottom
charging lower and lower and lower and
lower amounts
and if that's the game you're playing
you're not going to win you're not going
to get great clients those aren't the
clients that you want people are only
buying from you because of price that's
not an ideal client for you you have to
find a way
to be different to be unique to bring
more of yourself to your business to
give people a reason to talk about you
hey entrepreneurs we're all in
competitive fields there aren't too many
entrepreneurs who can say
oh yeah there's this huge market that
i'm reaching out to and i have no
competition
it's competitive it's a tough tough
world being an entrepreneur
you have to be unique and maybe that is
in your offering maybe you have unique
products that nobody else is selling
maybe you have a theme maybe you have
the most unique you know baseball themed
products whatever it is and you're going
to attract people who want baseball
products
maybe you have the best service in the
business maybe you have a mission that
people can believe in and you give a
portion of your sales to charity
something you need something that's
going to help stand out
because if you are just like everybody
else you're going to get mediocre to
below average results
the good news is here
most companies are not unique
you may not be unique right now but you
know what your competition isn't either
this gives you a great chance to stand
out
the way to start is think about what is
it that is special about you because
nobody else can be you nobody else can
bring you to your business what do you
believe in what are some of your other
passions how can you bring that to your
business
so you're the best guy at promotional
products for this industry or who
believes in these values
something if you could bring that in
then you're going to bring people who
are like-minded with you who love what
you're all about who want to share your
stuff who want to buy from you and
they'll be great customers and they'll
buy more from you and they'll refer
customers on to you
they'll talk about you
it's so critical
most entrepreneurs never go through this
step they just try to look at how can i
make some money in this business
and if that's all you're looking at
you're going to fail you're not going to
get great results
so really for the next week think about
what makes you so unique and how you can
bring more of that flavor into your
business to help you stand out
for any entrepreneur who's in a
competitive business
it's one of the most important things
you have to do if you can't figure that
out you're not going to have success but
when you do
you're going to have a line
of ideal customers who believe in what
you believe
coming to you because nobody is doing
this your competition is not doing this
the top people in your business are
barely doing this
there's always room for quality at the
top and if you can position yourself to
be unique and stand for something
important and have a unique offering
the market is yours and i want to hear
about your success
believe
for those of you watching like the video
please give it a thumbs up below and i
want to hear what you have to think
leave a comment below you have a
question leave it below i'll make a
response for you thank you so much and
i'll see you soon